Claude bonsoir le président du Pakistan
le président Zia a été tué tout à
l'heure dans l'explosion de son avion
accident ou attentat rien n'est sûr mais
sa mort pourrait provoquer des
changements dans cette région du monde
ultime négociation à Paris sur la
Nouvelle-Calédonie Michel Rocard ira fin
août dans le territoire Louis lepins
secs ministre des DOM-TOM et l'invité de
ce journal la France proteste contre la
guerre économique que les États-Unis
s'apprêtent à nous livrer il s'agit d'un
projet de loi américain très
protectionniste
le ticket républicain pour les élections
américaines ce sera bouche cuell George
Bush a choisi son vice-président cruel
est un jeune sénateur conservateur
Zurich ce soir le choc des deux géants
car Lewis contre Ben Johnson dernière
répétition avancée houle le meeting de
Zurich sur ADO
la mort du président dia le président du
Pakistan a été tué cet après-midi à la
suite de l'explosion de son avion
l'avion a ses 130 de l'armée
pakistanaise s'est écrasé peu après le
décollage et tous les passagers ont été
tués parmi les passagers il y avait
notamment l'ambassadeur des États-Unis
au Pakistan et le chef d'état-majeur de
l'armée pakistanaise la question c'est
bien sûr attentat ou accident impossible
de dire pour l'instant car aucune
indication n'a été donnée sur la nature
de l'explosion on sait simplement que
les débris de l'avion ont été éparpillés
sur une très large zone le président
pakistanais était un allié des
Américains George Bush le vice-président
qui est aussi le candidat américain pour
les républicains a dit tout à l'heure à
la Convention de La Nouvelle-Orléans que
la perte du général via était une grande
tragédie ce sont ces termes le président
Zia avait 64 ans il était au pouvoir
depuis 77 il était venu au pouvoir après
un coup d'État et il cumulé maintenant
toutes les fonctions de direction du
pays son portrait Jacques Merlino avait
fêté le depuis juillet dernier le 11ème
anniversaire de sa prise du pouvoir un
pouvoir conquit le force en 1977 par un
coup d'État après avoir renversé et fait
exécuter le Premier ministre de l'époque
Jules ficcard albuto le général Zia
avait promis un retour très rapide à la
démocratie promesse non tenue durant 8
ans aucune consultation populaire ne fut
organisée et la loi martiale
s'appliquait à tous ceux qui tentaient
d'avoir une activité politique dans le
même temps le général Zia décidait de
faire respecter à l'extrême la loi
islamique des centaines de personnes
furent pendues des milliers flageller
publiquement pour avoir commis des actes
contraires au Coran dans ce climat très
dur très lourd les réactions populaires
se firent d'abord dans le désordre sous
la forme d'émeutes exposant plus ou
moins spontanément les tentatives
d'élection en 1983 et 1985 furent
dénoncé par l'opposition comme autant de
mascarade une opposition qui avait
trouvé un leader en la personne de la
fille de l'ancien Premier ministre
Benazir buto à la tête du mouvement pour
la restauration de la démocratie elle
jouit d'un grand prestige dans la
population et c'est évidemment vers elle
que se tourne maintenant tous les
regards mais la disparition accidentelle
du chef de l'État pakistanais doit être
resitué dans un contexte géographique et
politique car c'est par le Pakistan que
transitait toute l'aide à la résistance
afghane et cette au Pakistan que 300 000
réfugiés afghan ont trouvé refuge
alors je le disais tout à l'heure
impossible de savoir s'il s'agit d'un
accident ou d'un attentat Jacques
Merlino impossible ce soir de dire on
peut pas le dire c'est encore beaucoup
trop tôt mais ce qui est certain c'est
que cela se produit à une date qui n'est
pas neutre pourquoi et bien parce qu'il
y a deux jours les Soviétiques célébrai
le départ de la moitié de leur troupe
qui combattait en Afghanistan et toutes
ces troupes doivent se retirer ici le
mois de février prochain or très peu
d'observateurs pensent que l'armée
régulière puisse tenir seule contre les
différents mouvements de résistance
d'autant que ces mouvements trouvaient
un appui très fort au Pakistan ça pêche
à voir que sont installés les différents
chefs de la résistance c'est là que sont
stockés toutes les armes qui servent
cette résistance le Pakistan c'est donc
la véritable base arrière de tous ceux
qui s'opposent au président afghan
najiboula et le général Zia qui avait
fait de son pays une république
islamique qui nous avons vu sur ces
images avec quelle violence sinon quelle
fanatisme cette loi est appliqué le
général Zian ne voulait entendre parler
en aucune manière de négociation avec le
président najiboula sa disparition donc
d'une certaine manière calme un peu les
tensions dans cette région et atténue le
risque de voir un jour peut-être
s'installer en Afghanistan une
république islamique mais cette
conclusion doit aussi tôt être nuancée
le pays le Pakistan est un pays d'une
très grande fragilité et nul ne peut
dire encore s'il saisira la chance de
s'engager dans une voie démocratique ou
si à notre général prolongera la
dictature militaire merci Jacques voilà
donc ce qu'on pouvait dire ce soir sur
la mort du président pakistanais la mort
du président Zia tué tout à l'heure dans
Nasan accident d'avion l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie c'est ce dont on
discute en ce moment à Paris au
ministère des DOM-TOM les deux
délégations FLNKS et RPCR sont présentes
et on a appris cet après-midi que Michel
Rocard irait dans le territoire fin août
précisément les 26 27 et 28 août
cependant il n'est pas sûr que l'accord
final soit prêt pour que le référendum
ait bien lieu fin septembre comme prévu
compte-rendu de la première séance de
négociation Rachid arabe
près de 30 heures d'avion ça use arrivée
ce matin d'un voyage de 20000 km pas
encore remis d'un décalage horaire de 9h
les deux délégations du FLNKS et du RPCR
ont pourtant commencé leur marathon de
discussion dès cet après-midi rue
Oudinot
Jean-Marie dibao a apparemment moins
dormi que dit ouais dans l'avion à la
tête du RPCR et surtout en l'absence du
leader Jacques Lafleur le sénateur
ukiway c'est qu'il aura fort à faire
pendant les trois ou quatre jours que
vont durer les discussions Jean-Marie
dibao lui aussi joue une partie
importante au cours de ces conversations
autour de Louis Lepin sec le ministre
des DOM-TOM qui a présenté au délégation
l'avant-projet de loi sur l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie à Clermont rejeté
deux des demandes formulées par le FLNKS
l'amnistie totale sur le territoire et
le remodelage du corps électoral qui
s'exprimera pour ou contre
l'indépendance dans 10 ans le fallen KS
prendra-t-il pour autant le risque de
claquer la porte rien n'est moins sûr
d'autant plus que Jean-Marie Djibaou a
déjà laissé entendre qu'il était prêt à
discuter des mesures d'accompagnement
notamment économique proposé par le
gouvernement bref pour l'instant
personne ne semble avoir intérêt à
rompre d'autant que Michel Rocard a bien
choisi son moment pour annoncer son
prochain voyage en Nouvelle-Calédonie
une façon comme une autre de mettre les
deux délégations au pied du mur
voilà donc pour cette première réunion
qui vient de s'achever Rachid nous le
disait avec nous en direct le ministre
des DOM-TOM Monsieur Louis lepinsèque
bonsoir Monsieur le Ministre alors tout
le monde était optimiste c'est en
dernier à propos de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie puis hier vous avez
dit que le référendum n'aurait peut-être
pas lieu comme prévu le 25 septembre je
crois qu'il faut en venir à l'essentiel
l'essentiel se trouve dans dans le fait
que aujourd'hui les deux délégations au
ministère des DOM-TOM ont pu engager
très concrètement des discussions dans
une ambiance dont je dois dire
qu'elle était très marquée par la
sérénité des échanges par une attitude
très studieuse marquée à certains
moments faut-il le dire par l'émotion
mais est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que il va falloir un petit peu plus de
temps que prévu peut-être et bien nous
sommes des la première réunion de
travail qui vient de s'achever nous nous
sommes mis d'accord sur une méthode de
travail et sur un calendrier
végétaux délai que dès demain j'aurai
des rencontres bilatérales avec la
délégation du RPCR et du FLNKS et nous
sommes convenus de reprendre demain soir
en séance plénière l'examen du projet de
loi que j'ai présenté je dirais ce soir
dans sa globalité les sociétés j'ai bien
cruauté dans chacune des délégations une
volonté de conduire à bonne fin de la
discussion avant la fin de la semaine
puisque tout le monde est convenu que le
dimanche devait être rendu à ce qui est
sa vocation première et non pas le
travail alors venons-en au point
litigieux il y avait Rachid arabe le
rappeler le problème de l'amnistie alors
sur ce plan pas d'amnistie totale c'est
ce que disait Rachid
j'ai donné lecture de ce qui est prévu
dans le projet de loi ainsi que je le
disais j'aurais des discussions
bilatérales je ne doute pas que nous
ayons l'occasion au fil des heures et
des tout prochains jours de revenir sur
ce point j'ai toujours
dit qu'en ce domaine les marges de
manœuvre étaient étroite mais j'ai aussi
dit que disposer à ce qui est la
concertation j'étais prêt à examiner un
certain nombre d'amendements au projet
pour autant qu'ils aient l'accord de
l'autre partie il n'est pas exclu que
sur un certain nombre de points les deux
délégations ne formulent de concert
quelques aménagements surtout en tout
cas le sentiment que l'on peut avoir à
l'issue de cette première réunion de
travail Michel Rocard va le 26 août sur
le territoire on l'a dit tout à l'heure
alors est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il
partira là-bas avec un accord en poche
signé le Premier ministre a annoncé sa
venue sur le territoire il a aussi
précisé qu'elle était sans lien avec ce
qui est l'avancée des discussions et de
nos travaux ceci était un projet prévu
d'assez longue date
le climat de nos discussions les
premiers échanges que nous avons pu
avoir me laisse assez optimiste sur la
possibilité d'arriver en fin de semaine
à ce qui serait un accord global pour
l'avenir de la merci Monsieur le
Ministre la France proteste contre la
guerre économique que s'apprête à livrer
les États-Unis c'était au Conseil des
ministres ce matin c'était d'ailleurs le
Conseil des ministres de rentrée il
reprend en effet son rythme hebdomadaire
après la pause estivale il y avait
autour de la table et à la sortie
quelques ministres bronzés le plus
important de ce conseil a donc été la
protestation de la France la France
condamne sévèrement un projet de loi
américain sur le commerce c'est un
projet intitulé Le trade Bill si le
gouvernement américain ratifie ce projet
ce qui est très probable il adoptera une
attitude très protectionniste dans les
échanges commerciaux ce serait le début
d'une véritable guerre commerciale déjà
par le passé il y a eu beaucoup
d'exemples de relations économiques
difficiles entre l'Europe et les
États-Unis Claire Chazal
Ronald Reagan a donc cédé devant le
Congrès les Américains vont serrer d'un
cran leur ligne de défense contre les
produits
étranges et d'abord sur l'agriculture
les États-Unis ont toujours reproché aux
Européens de subventionner leur fermier
et ils ont fermé à plusieurs reprises
leurs frontières à nos céréales nos
poulets ou nos cognac la nouvelle loi
sur le protectionnisme prévoit
d'ailleurs en retour une aide de 2
millions et demi de dollars aux
agriculteurs du midelwest
particulièrement touchés par la
sécheresse
mais l'industrie européenne n'est pas
non plus épargnée par le repli sur soi
américain ce fut la guerre de l'acier au
début des années 80 et les droits
supplémentaires imposés par les
États-Unis à notre tôle où nos barres de
fer
mais c'est surtout l'Airbus qui reste
aujourd'hui au centre de la bataille les
Américains ont peur de la concurrence de
plus en plus vives de l'avion européen
et négocie ferme à Genève pour taxer les
appareils importés cela dit le nouveau
texte vise avant tout le Japon aux
usines hyper performantes qui vont
toujours aux Américains beaucoup plus
qui ne leur achètent sanctionnaient déjà
l'entreprise Toshiba par exemple dont
les produits sont désormais interdits de
ces jours pendant trois ans sur le sol
américain un déficit extérieur
persistant l'approche des élections
Regan ne pouvait qu'encourager son
administration à durcir la guerre
commerciale engagée depuis des années
avec le reste du monde
remontée du dollar à Paris 6 francs 43
contre 6 francs 39 hier
ose de la Bourse aussi
1,28% de progression pour l'indicateur
de tendance des valeurs françaises Paris
suis New York Wall Street et les autres
marchés financiers qui curieusement ont
réagit plutôt positivement à
l'annoncière d'un gros déficit
commercial américain journée d'action de
la CGT dans plusieurs villes de France à
Paris par exemple 3500 personnes
manifestées devant chez Renault avec à
leur tête henri Krasucki pour que la loi
d'amnistie s'applique très largement au
licencié dans les entreprises 10
licenciés des usines de Billancourt
était d'ailleurs symboliquement présent
Jean-Pierre Métivet
si Jean-François carré
j'appelle également Gérard jagoule les
10 de Renault Billancourt les voici un
symbole pour la CGT derrière leurs
affiches dans l'usine fermée le comité
d'entreprise a dit oui ce matin alors
réintégration seulement voilà en
principe ils sont exclus de la loi
d'amnistie pour cause d'actions
violentes sanctionnée en correctionnelle
il est donc pas sûr du tout que la
direction accepte finalement l'aurait
intégration cela c'est le cas ultime
mise en avant par la CGT qui présente
partout actuellement des demandes de
réintégration de syndicalistes et se bat
pour une application très large de la
loi d'amnistie
à noter aussi le ton offensif de Henri
krazuki ce matin annonçant un
développement des luttes tous azimuts
bien voir que tout est en mouvement et
que nous sommes dans les premiers temps
d'un processus qui ouvre un champ dont
on ne peut mesurer aujourd'hui
toute l'étendue la CGT se doit d'agir en
conséquence il faut
y aller
si la CGT frappe déjà les trois coups de
la rentrée sociale c'est pour prendre de
vitesse les autres syndicats car c'est
rentré risque d'être plus agitée un
signe le nombre de journées de grève au
cours des quatre premiers mois à doubler
par rapport aux années précédentes
peut-être un renversement de tendance
dans ce cas la centrale de Henry crazyki
entend bien en être la locomotive
dans un instant nous allons parler de la
convention républicaine aux États-Unis
et de George Bush qui s'est choisi un
vice-président il s'agit de Dan Creil
mais tout de suite d'autres télégrammes
d'actualité avec Claude Crespo
bourride d'armes et de munitions cette
consigne de la gare Montparnasse c'est
un coup de téléphone anonyme qui a
permis à la brigade criminelle de faire
cette découverte à l'intérieur entre
autres une grenade incendiaire cette
cocktail Molotov des détonateurs quatre
grenades et plusieurs pistolets
mitrailleurs les armes sont anciennes
selon la police elles n'ont a priori
aucun lien avec une cage d'armes
terroriste
érable la 205 du triangle infernal de
Lyon une voiture semblable à celle-ci
les trois hommes qui a son bord en
commis si d'agressions depuis samedi
semblent s'en être débarrassé dans un
canal au sud de Tain-l'Hermitage pas de
trad accident la chute du véhicule
serait délibérée depuis malgré de
nombreux barrages les meurtriers n'ont
toujours pas été retrouvés
plus de 100km2 c'est la nouvelle
catastrophe qui touche le Soudan ces
nuages qui viennent de l'Est ont déjà
ratissé tous les pays traversés dans le
Niger des milliers de kilomètres carrés
envahis que restera-t-il du Soudan après
leur passage quand déjà les inondations
ont fait 90 morts et sont cause de la
disparition de 115 000 habitants dans la
capitale même cartoon
la candidature de l'ancien président
Souleymane Frangy et soutenu par la
Syrie provoque de vives réactions de la
ministre chrétienne des Forces
libanaises cette bombe ont explosé la
nuit dernière à Beyrouth Ouest dans le
quartier musulman cette série d'États
qui n'a fait aucune victime intervient à
moins de 48 heures de la réunion du
Parlement en séance électorale
le ticket républicain ce sera donc
bouche qual en effet aux élections
américaines vous savez que le candidat
président se présente avec son candidat
vice-président George Bush a donc
annoncé à la Convention de La
Nouvelle-Orléans que son colistier ce
serait donc dan kwell un sénateur de 41
ans en physique de Playboy ce choix
surpris tout le monde politique
américain Philippe le fait
parenthèse sur grand écran certains de
ses amis voient en lui le Robert Redford
de la politique la réponse est non
d'ailleurs depuis 1980 l'acteur ne porte
pas le jeune politicien dans son cœur
dan Kell 41 ans a un loup une fougue et
une ardeur qui font la popularité dans
l'électorat féminin avocat de formation
c'est un héritier de grande famille de
celles qui font les jeunesses dorées et
qui lui font dire la vie a été très
bonne pour moi marié une avocate perd de
trois enfants on le soupçonne pourtant
d'une aventure avec une jeune femme qui
pose la nu dans Playboy il dément entrée
en politique à 29 ans Dan kweil et le
prototype des jeunes conservateurs il
est tout naturellement le joker de
George Bush le candidat républicain qui
se veut un digne successeur de Regan
mais qui n'a été de fait qu'un discret
second les caricaturistes ne s'y
trompent pas qui font dire à Ronald
Reagan quand il s'adresse à George Bush
veinard vous serez mieux secondé que moi
au Sénat on dit le jeune homme capable
d'initiative et d'aud Ace ne
propose-t-il pas de rationaliser les
dépenses militaires mais quoi il a
surtout pour lui une carte il plait aux
ultras conservateurs dans ses prises de
position pour la peine de mort ou pour
la guerre des étoiles cher à Ronald
Reagan bouche le modéré discret quael le
jeune et le dur le ticket républicain
cheveu équilibré et choc commentaires de
Dan kweil à la Nouvelle-Orléans on les
aura question de style
la convention républicaine c'est à la
Nouvelle-Orléans en Louisiane vous le
savez la Convention démocrate il y a à
peine un mois c'était atlantin Géorgie
dans le sud aussi et ce n'est pas un
hasard les états majeurs politiques ont
besoin des voix des États du Sud il
s'agit donc de leur faire les yeux doux
reportage Jacques à Bouchard
adepte de l'intolérance la plus brutale
les hommes du Ku Klux Klan incarnait un
Sud aujourd'hui moribond mais si la
violence y est en recul le culte de la
tradition demeure vivace et dans une
Amérique gagnée par le reganisme les
conservateurs des deux bords
républicains comme démocrate ont compris
tout le parti qu'il pouvait tirer en
organisant leur convention dans deux
villes sudistes Atlanta et la
Nouvelle-Orléans
depuis John Kennedy en 1960 le sud
autrefois sanctuaire démocrate a basculé
du côté républicain
le démocrate texan Lindon Johnson a bien
freiner les morragies mais elle a repris
inexorablement sous les présidents
républicaines d'abord de Richard Nixon
puis plus tard de Gérald Ford et depuis
1980 de Ronald Reagan
en fait seul Jimmy Carter fils de la
très sudiste Géorgie avait réussi à
renverser provisoirement la tendance et
il semble bien qu'en 1988 le sud se
laisse davantage courtiser par
l'éléphant républicain que par l'un
démocrates
une voix il aime l'attitude républicain
sur l'importance de la famille par sur
l'importance de la lutte contre les
drogues en patients de drogue et aussi
dans l'importance de l'industrie de
défense des États-Unis
que les démocrates
alors votre sentiment c'est que bouche
va gagner dans le sud oui je pense qu'il
va gagner
en tout cas George Bush s'est donné un
bon atout pour y parvenir avec le choix
comme-colistier du fougueux sénateur de
l'Indiana dans quoi il est beau il est
jeune riche et plus encore il est très
conservateur
trouble permanent et successifs dans les
territoires occupés par Israël depuis
trois jours maintenant le couvre-feu est
institué à Gaza il y a des affrontements
il y aurait des blessés d'autre part une
grève générale a été très suivie dans
les territoires ce mercredi au lendemain
de la mort de deux prisonniers
palestiniens dans un centre de détention
en Israël explication de Jérusalem
Charles
d'après ce que l'on sait les détenus
attendait une réponse du commandant du
camp à une liste de doléances remise la
veille elle n'est pas venue et à 16h
hier des centaines de prisonniers ont
commencé à manifester lançant des
pierres et des piquets de tente sur les
soldats qui ont riposter au gaz
lacrymogène puis on tirer l'armée a
ouvert une enquête et 2500 détenus de
kyotes se plaignent depuis des mois de
leur condition de détention les juges de
la Haute Cour de justice israélienne ont
même décidé de se rendre en personne sur
place les détenus ne font pas en général
l'état de brutalité mais plutôt
d'insultes et d'une atmosphère
psychologique très dur
il n'a rien à purger 4 mois de détention
administrative action on nous insulte
durant l'appel 3 fois par jour nous
devons y participer à s'y en tailleur
par le soleil à l'appel de son numéro de
détenus chacun doit se tourner sans se
lever nous a confisqué même notre nom
les conditions sanitaires sont
déplorables la nourriture est
particulièrement la viande un mangeable
les événements de tiote ont durci les
quelques manifestations qui se sont
déroulées aujourd'hui en si Jordan voici
près de Jérusalem les obsèques d'un
Palestinien décédé en prison selon la
police il s'est suicidé l'appel à la
grève générale du comité clandestin du
soulèvement a été massivement suivi
un grave accident de train en Union
soviétique le Léningrad Moscou a
déraillé puis a pris feu le drame s'est
déroulé à mi-chemin entre les deux
villes le bilan serait lourd il y aurait
officiellement 17 morts et une centaine
de blessés et puis une prise d'otages en
Allemagne elle dure maintenant depuis 36
heures des gangsters qui avaient attaqué
une banque à gladbeg dans la roue ont
pris en personne deux otages et puis
tout à l'heure ils se sont emparés d'un
autobus et ils ont maintenant 30
personnes en otage ça se passe donc à
Gladbeck dans la roue
Ferrari continue après la mort d'Enzo
Ferrari la firme de Maranello poursuit
sa production et la compétition il faut
dire que Fiat est maintenant
l'actionnaire principal aujourd'hui les
Ferrari de Formule 1 faisaient des
essais privés sur la piste de Monza
reportage Lionel Chamoulaud
et pourtant elle tourne Monza et ses
privées les Ferrari sont en piste aucun
signe extérieur de deuil toujours la
même discrétion autour de la disparition
du commandateur certainement que chacun
pense à lui principalement Michael
alboretto et après beaucoup des années
avec
laquelle elle peut parler tous les jours
pourquoi je suis italienne elle lui a
jamais parlé des autres langages sont
restés en contact très serrées
l'Autrichien gerhart burger lui et le
dernier pilote engagé par Enzo Ferrari
c'était plus qu'un patron à lui seul il
représentait le sport automobile et
toute la ferveur toute la magie qu'il y
a autour
la course continue le travail aussi
c'était la religion d'Enzo Ferrari
l'équipe compétition prépare le prochain
Grand Prix celui de Belgique
le sport avec le choc de deux géants du
stade car Lewis contre Ben Johnson sur
100 mètres c'est le match de l'année ça
devrait être même être le duel des Jeux
olympiques de Séoul ce serait en
principe la finale ce soir azurique pour
une seule et unique fois avancée ou
justement les deux hommes Lewis et Ben
Johnson se retrouvent les suit son mille
paquets pour les avoir ce meeting de
Zurich sera retransmis sur Antenne 2 ce
soir juste après la dernière édition du
journal mais tout de suite présentation
du combat Patrick Naf
voilà ça c'était les images des des deux
dernières courses de Ben Johnson et de
Carl Lewis qui jusqu'à présent c'était
pas rencontré sur la distance du 100m et
qui est évitait le plus possible de se
rencontrer sur ces distances et donc au
meeting de Zurich ce soir Lewis face à
Benz Hanson ce sera le combat de l'année
tout de suite je pense que nous pouvons
peut-être avoir les premières épreuves
le résumé des premières épreuves qui se
sont courues dans ce meeting de Zurich
peut-être le 100 mètres féminin ou le
400 mètres on va voir si nous pouvons
les avoir
oui
avec Lewis Reynolds
avec un bon départ de tous les
concurrents et en particulier de
innocents
très très fort alors que derrière et
bien au couloir un Roberto Hernandez de
Cuba qui a réalisé 44 22 à Mexico au
mois de mai parti à l'accord d'aussi
très très vite est-ce que vous [__] va
tenir est-ce que reynolds va revenir
dans la ligne droite on va voir à la
sortie du virage avec Renaud qui se
rapproche ainsi que Steve Lewis
et c'est pas très mal qui sort
effectivement en tête et que vous niquez
la plus tenir et ses rennes qui se
détachent dans la ligne droite et qui va
la porter très très facilement tant
attend extraordinaire
43 ans record du monde du 400 mètres
c'est fabuleux extraordinaire peut créer
un record du monde explosé
voilà vous l'avez vécu presque en direct
un record du monde du 400 mètres qui
vient d'être battu à Zurich ça promet
pour la soirée et je vous le disais
retransmission sur Antenne 2 tout à
l'heure après la dernière édition du
journal vous verrez donc ce fameux choc
car Lewis Ben Johnson ce sera vers 23h45
auparavant il faut que je vous donne les
pronostics du Tiercé Quarté plus c'est
un Enghien demain voici les pronostics
de Pierrette bref il y a 16 partants 13
9 4 10 11 8 6 et 7 donc 23h25 à peu près
Philippe le sait pour la dernière
édition du journal et ensuite le meeting
de Zurich retransmission une trentaine
de mes tout de suite aussitôt après la
fin de ce journal vous avez rendez-vous
pour une météo complète avec Laurent
Cabrol bonne soirée sur Antenne 2
Annemasse soir